This lecture is about the syntagmatic
relation discovery and mutual
information.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue discussing syntagmatic
relation discovery.
In particular, we're going to talk
about another concept, the information
theory, called mutual information.
And how it can be used to discover
syntagmatic relations?
Before we talked about a problem of
conditional entropy, and that is the
conditional entropy computed on
different pairs of words is not really
comparable, so that makes it hard to
discover strong syntagmatic relations
globally from corpus.
So now we're going to introduce mutual
information, which is another concept
in information theory that allows us
to, in some sense, normalize the
conditional entropy to make.
a more comparable across different
pairs.
In particular, mutual information,
denoted by I(X;Y), measures
the entropy reduction of X obtained from
knowing Y.
More specifically the question we're
interested in here, is how much
reduction in the entropy of X can we
obtain by knowing Y.
So mathematically, it can be defined as
the difference between the original
entropy of X and the conditional
entropy of X given Y.
And you might see here you can see
here.
It can also be defined as a reduction
of entropy of Y, because of knowing
X.
Normally the two conditional entropies
H(X|Y) and H(Y|X) are
not equal.
But interestingly,
the reduction of entropy
by knowing one of them is actually
equal, so this quantity is called
mutual information denoted by I here
and this function has some interesting
properties.
First, it's also non negative.
This is easy to understand becausw the
original entropy is always not going to
be lower than the
possibly reduced conditional
entropy.
In other words, the conditional entropy
would never exceed the original entropy.
Knowing some information can always
help us potentially, but won't hurt us
in predicting X.
The second property is that it's
symmetric while conditional entropy is
not symmetrical.
Mutual information is.
The third property is that
it reaches its minimum zero if and only
if the two random variables are
completely independent.
That means knowing one of them doesn't
tell us anything about the other.
And this last property can be verified
by simply looking at the equation
above.
And it reaches 0 if and only if the
conditional entropy of X given Y is
exactly the same as original entropy of
X.
So that means knowing why did not help
at all, and that's when X&Y are
completely independent.
Now when we fix X to rank different
Ys using conditional entropy would
give the same order as ranking based on
mutual information, because in the
function here H of X is fixed because X
is fixed.
So ranking based on mutual information
is exactly the same as ranking based on
the conditional entropy of X given Y.
But the mutual information allows us to
compare different pairs of X&Y, so
that's why mutual information is more
general and in general more useful.
So let's examine them intuition of
using mutual information for syntagmatic
relation mining.
Now the question we ask for syntactic
relation mining is whenever eats
occurs, what other words also tend to
occur?
So this question can be framed as a
mutual information question, that is,
which was have higher mutual
information with eats.
So we're going to compute the mutual
information between eats and other
words.
And if we do that, and it's basically a
based on the same intuition as in
conditional entropy, we will see that
words that are strongly associated with
each will tend to have high mutual
information, whereas words that are not
related.
We have lower mutual information, so
this I give some example here.
The mutual information between eats
and meats, which is the same as between
meats and eats cause major information
is symmetric is expected to be higher
than
The mutual information between eats and
the.
Because knowing the doesn't really
help us predict eats. Similarly knowing
eats doesn't help us predicting the as
well.
And you also can easily see that the
mutual information between  a word and
itself is the largest which is equal to
the mutual info.
The entropy of this word.
So because in this case the
reduction is maximum
because knowing one would allow us to
predict the other completely so the
conditional entropy is zero.
Therefore the mutual information
reaches its maximum.
It's going to be
larger than or equal to the mutual information
between eats and another word.
In other words, picking any other
word, and computing mutual information
between eats and that word,
you won't get any mutual information
larger than the mutual information
between eats and itself.
So now let's think about how to compute
the mutual information.
Now, in order to do that, we often.
use a different form of mutual
information, and we can mathematically
write the mutual information into the
form shown on this slide, where we
essentially see a formula that computes
what's called KL-divergences or
callback labeler divergance.
This is another term in information
theory that measures the divergance
between two distributions.
Now if you look at the formula, it's
also sum over many combinations of
different values of the two random
variables, but inside the sum mainly
we're doing a comparison between 2
joint distributions.
The numerator has the joint actual
observed.
Join the distribution of the two random
variables.
The bottom part of the denominator can
be interpreted as the expected joint
distribution of the two random
variables.
If there were independent.
Because when two random variables are
independent, they joined distribution
is equal to the product of the two
probabilities.
So this comparison would tell us
whether the two variables are indeed
independent if there indeed
independent, then we would expect that
the two are the same.
But if the numerator is different from
the denominator, that would mean the
two variables are not independent, and
that helps measure the association.
The sum is simply to take into
consideration of all the combinations
of the values of these two random
variables.
In our case, each random variable can
choose one of the two values 0 or 1, so we
have four combinations here.
So if we look at this form of mutual
information it shows that the mutual
information measures the diversions of
the actual joint distribution from the
expected distribution under the
independence assumption.
The larger this divergence is, the higher
the mutual information would be.
So now let's further look at the what
are exactly the probabilities involved
in this formula of mutual information.
And here I listed all the probabilities
involved and it's easy for you to
verify that basically we have first 2
probabilities corresponding to the
presence or absence of each word.
So for W1, we have two probabilities
shown here.
They should sum to 1 because a word can
either be present or absent in the
segment.
And similarly for the second word, we
also have two probabilities
representing presence or absence of
this word, and this sums to one
as well.
And then finally we have a lot of joint
probabilities that represented the
scenarios of Co-occurrences of the two
words.
And they are shown here.
Right, so this sums to 1 because
the two words can only have these four
possible scenarios.
Either they both occur.
So in that case both variables will
have a value of one or one of them
occurs.
There are two scenarios.
In these two cases, one of the random
variables will be equal to 1 and the
other would be 0.
And finally we have the scenario when
none of them occurs.
So this is when the two variables
taking a value of 0.
And they're summing up to 1, so these
are the probabilities involved in the
calculation of mutual information.
here.
Once we know how to calculate these
probabilities, we can easily calculate
the mutual information.
It's also interesting to
note that there are some
relations or constraints among these
probabilities, and we already saw two
of them, so the in the previous slide
that you have seen that the
marginal probabilities of these words
sum to one, and we also have seen this
constraint
that says the two words can only have
these four different scenarios of Co
occurrences, but we also have some
additional constraints listed in the
bottom.
And so, for example, this one means
if we add up the probabilities that we
observe the two words occur together
and the probabilities when the word
the first word occurs and the second
word doesn't occur, we get exactly the
probability that the first word is
observed.
In other words, and when the word is
observed when the first word is
observed and there are only two
scenarios depending on weather second
word is also observed.
So this probability captures the first
scenario when the signal word actually
is also observed.
And this captures the second scenario
when the seond word is not observed,
so we only see the first word.
And it's easy to see the other
equations also follow the same
reasoning.
Now these equations allow us to compute
some probabilities based on other
probabilities.
And this can simplify the computation.
So more specifically, and if we know the
probability that a word is present, and
in this case right?
So if we know this.
And if we know the presence of the
probability of presence of the second
word, then we can easily compute their
absence probability, right?
It's very easy to use this equation
to do that.
An so we this will take care of the
computation of these probabilities of
presence or absence of each word.
Now let's look at their joint
distribution, right?
Let's assume that we also have
available probability that they
occur together.
Now it's easy to see that we can
actually compute the all the rest of
these probabilities based on these.
Specifically, for example, using this
equation, we can compute the
probability that the first word
occurred and the second word did not,
because we know these probabilities in
the boxes.
And similarly, using this equation we
can compute the probability that we
observe only the second word.
And then finally we.
This probability can be calculated by
using this equation, because now this
is known and this is also known and
this is already known right?
So this can be easier to calculate.
Right, so now this can be calculated.
So this slide shows that we only need
to know how to compute these three
probabilities that are shown in the
boxes, namely the presence of each word
and the Co occurrence of both words in
a segment.